thank you so as you said my name is Mike
West you can get all the vital details
up there it's really just an exercise to
see how many times I can type my quest
on the same page the slides are actually
online right now I'm using speaker duck
because speaker 2 is awesome and my
computer decided hey I'm not going to
connect to the laptop they're to the
projector so if you want to follow along
with the slides you can grab them right
now I'd suggest you just you know hop
over there take a look at the slides and
look at the master words as well because
what I really want to do today is give
you an introduction to a kind of wide
field of things that can go wrong on
your site specifically I want to talk
about content injection attacks content
injection is probably the most pervasive
problem on the web from a security
perspective absolutely every website
will have a content injection hole of
one sort or another at one time or
another it's really difficult to do
things correctly we all make mistakes
Google makes mistakes and if Google is
making mistakes with teams that are
actually dedicated to security reviewing
all the code you can be damn sure that
you guys are gonna make mistakes as well
does anyone actually have a full-time
security person on their team I am
actually shocked there are people with
their hands up usually everyone sits
there and stunned silent saying what pay
someone to work on security that's crazy
generally speaking security gets is is
generally pushed to the end we usually
worry about security when it's too late
once we found a hole on the site as
opposed to worrying about it up front I
think that should probably change but
let's talk about content injection
content injection happens when you
either a one mechanism of content
injection is poor escaping so you get
some content from a user you escape it
incorrectly and then write it out to the
page what you see here is a relatively
exhaustive list of the contexts in which
code can be output to a site so you have
a color in a style tag you have a user
name directly inside of an HTML elements
you have a URL that's inside of an
attribute
have a user ID that's written directly
into script and you have some debug
information put into a comment for each
of these contexts the rules are
different for example if I have two
dashes inside of a comment that actually
closes the comment two dashes inside of
a pee tag of course have absolutely no
effect other than writing out two dashes
to the page you need to be very careful
about the ways that you escape data when
you write it out to the page you need to
know the context in which you're writing
out data and you need to make sure that
you escape the information correctly for
that context it's honestly trivial to do
all you have to do is be perfect you
simply have to know all of the rules and
apply them perfectly every time you read
out any data data that's coming from you
data that's reflected from the Dom data
that's coming from get parameters every
single time you have to be perfect it's
kind of difficult to do why is content
ejection important well to understand
that you have to understand the concept
of an origin an origin is a pairing of a
scheme a host and a port so HTTP
example.com 80 or HTTPS Google comm 443
those are two distinct origins and the
browser can guarantee that those origins
should never have direct access to
information from the other origin
example.com must never be able to access
for instance cookies from Google com or
local storage or any of a number of
other html5 storage mechanisms you're
kind of already familiar with this
concept with regard to JavaScript
because JavaScript has a number of ways
in which it can be a injected into a
page and be read interesting data like
cookies and then exfiltrate that data
out to a third party of course solving
content injection on the web is simple
right we just turn off JavaScript and
we're done easy just tell all your users
to go into content settings turn off
JavaScript on every web page and they
will never have another content
injection problem again sure someone
might write some content on your page
but it's just text it won't actually
execute so how could anything dangerous
happen I am here to talk about the
things there's an excellent paper and
most of the things that I'm going to
talk about today come from come from
Mario and come from this paper and a
number of others that he's published
I don't do attack research I am not the
right guy for that but I want to talk
about it a little bit just to give you
some context so that then at the end of
this talk I can talk about the things
that I think are important defense I can
show you how to harden your website
against these kinds of attacks and also
against all the other kinds of
cross-site scripting attacks out there I
actually really recommend that you take
a look at this paper it's kind of an
academic paper but it's really easy to
read and it walks through a lot of the
concepts that I'll be talking about here
and again all the slides are online
you'll see the URL at the end again what
I'm not going to talk about although I
find it incredibly interesting are
timing attacks timing attacks I would
love to talk about them but they require
JavaScript and because of that I cannot
talk about them at CSS comp but I can
show you this white paper this was
presented I think in June of this year
and it's it is absolutely stunning what
you can do simply by looking at how the
browser renders things this guy gives
you an excellent mechanism by which you
can detect whether or not a user has
visited a page the history attacks we
basically shut those down via JavaScript
in other words you can't directly read
the style of a visited link however if
you're very clever and you read the
paper it's absolutely incredible he can
actually read individual pixels across
origin through an iframe it's the most
amazing thing that I've seen in the last
couple of months I really highly
recommend you read it but that's not our
topic for today but we want to talk
about today our content injection
attacks and for a Content injection
attack to be successful it needs three
components there needs to be an
injection and I guarantee you that there
are injections on your page I'm not even
going to talk about it because it
happens everywhere it's really difficult
to avoid then it needs execution and for
JavaScript execution is quite clear the
code executes or it doesn't what I
propose is that execution should be you
should conceptually include things like
the application of style
if style executes on your page then
I'll show you some problems that can pop
up and then there needs to be some sort
of advantage for the attacker in that in
the most cases the advantage for the
attacker is exfiltration of interesting
information from your website this might
be a CSRF token we'll talk about those
in a moment it might be a password it
might be the user's bank account
information anytime the attacker can get
secret information from a page and
exfiltrate it to a third party server to
a server that they control then they've
gained some sort of advantage over you
we'll talk about how all of these can
happen within the context of CSS first
I'll talk about the obvious stuff
defacement phishing anything along these
lines if someone can inject style into
your page then by definition they can
change the way that your page looks and
to a certain extent they can change the
way your page behaves in the worst case
or in the most simple case they can
simply hide everything on your page and
change the background of your of your
page to something that you would not
like to have as your homepage these are
really trivial attacks there's nothing
really interesting to say about them
other than if someone can inject style
into your page they can change the way
your page looks and at best embarrass
you at worst trick users into clicking
on things that they shouldn't click on
so if you have a hole that allows
someone to inject style they can almost
certainly inject HTML as well if they
can inject HTML they could inject a form
they could inject a link and bring a
user to a page that the user isn't
expecting to go to a style injection
will help them with that it'll help them
take whatever they can inject and make
it look like it's supposed to be on your
page and make it very enticing for user
to click on so if your bank account
suddenly said hey here's five free euro
then you're probably going to click on
that button because hey five four euro
that's awesome of course my bank is
gonna give that to me because of that
any time the user that an attacker can
inject style into a page it's actually
more dangerous than you might think just
in terms of defacement but again that's
not particularly interesting because
it's kind of obvious what would be more
interesting is if we could take some
sort of secret information on the page
information that isn't actually visible
to the user and exfiltrated somehow so
for example every
time you have a form on a web site that
posts somewhere and does something in
the backend you generally want to make
sure that you are the only one that can
post to that URL one way to do that is
to have a CSRF token which basically
says you give each user a one-time pad
so here's a secret and then they use
that secret when they submit the form
because of course you can submit forms
from anywhere forms and posts are not
particularly hard to trick a user into
making this is why you want to make sure
that you give the user a secret and then
the user uses that secret to execute
something on the backend it'd be really
useful if an attacker could find some
way to pull that secret and give it over
to to themselves as opposed to only
having access to it within the context
of your page how could we go about doing
this it's an input element and we need
to use CSS in some way to apply style to
that element only when it meets certain
requirements one mechanism that we could
use of course is an attribute selector
attribute selectors are great they allow
us to apply Styles only when the
attribute matches a certain value so in
the worst case you can brute force the
value of an elements or have an
attribute on it elements by injecting a
whole lot of style or more appropriately
by injecting a link to a style sheet
such that the style sheet loads has a
whole lot of style information and the
CSRF token will be matched if it matches
a certain value so this shows you how
you would do it if the CSRF token was
binary most CSRF tokens are in fact not
binary they use a lot more characters
which means brute-forcing isn't
particularly fast it's actually quite
slow but once we have this once we were
able to match a value and of course you
don't have to use equals you can use
starts width you can use ends with it'd
be really nice if there was a reg axe of
some sort but there isn't I'm hoping
that comes up at some point really
excited about web components let's see
where we go with that I think that there
is so once you're able to inject script
or inject style and that style can not
certain elements on the page we still
have to have some mechanism by which we
give that information to a third party
happily CSS makes this quite trivial by
giving us the ability to load resources
from any URL on the web that's kind of
nice right so I'm gonna set a background
image on the CSRF taken of evil comm and
then CSRF equals zero and I'm going to
repeat this for every single brute-force
attack that I'm making so value equals
zero value equals one at some point I
will match the token and I will
exfiltrate that token out to a
third-party server the third party now
has the ability to if you can fish the
user in some way which is really trivial
then you'll know a CSRF token you'll
hope the user hasn't used it yet and
you'll be able to submit something that
actually has a fact as opposed to
something that doesn't this was talked
about it's way way back in 2009 it's I
think the presentation was called the
sexiest Assin which is a terrible name
for it and it's just a terrible name in
general I think they'd probably be
embarrassed about it now but the attack
is something like this I type yay and
then only using CSS they're able to
using front looking at the front looking
at the back and then combining those
selectors they're able to actually
detect what the value is across origins
which is actually kind of cool what this
proves is that simply with CSS you're
able to read the value of elements on a
page and you're able to exfiltrate that
information now this is relatively slow
we'll look at some things later on that
will speed it up and that will actually
make it more practical for an attack as
opposed to this brute force mechanism
which is kind of impractical the point
here is simply that execution and
exfiltration are not only possible but
quite plausible within the context of
CSS i'd recommend that you take a look
at this if you do
I think questions source then you see
the the PHP stuff this is relatively old
so the codes not awesome but it's
certainly worth looking through just to
see how it works so continuing what if
we wanted to steal a get parameter
instead of looking at something on the
page what if we wanted to look at the
URL of the document unfortunately this
only works in Firefox as a bug here that
you can star if you
to work in WebKit - I think that would
be interesting but there is an amazing
selector called Moz documents and Moz
document allows you to use a reg axe to
look at the name of the document to look
at the actual URL and then do some sort
of styling on the page based upon that
URL this is really really useful for
like user scripts people that are
injecting some sort of code into a page
they only want to have one style sheet
but they want to do slightly different
things on different pages it would also
give you the ability to kind of a poor
man's ability to scope style to a
certain section of your page you include
the same style sheet on every page in
your in your site but you have certain
styles that apply to your homepage
certain styles that apply to your about
page something along those lines there
are some use cases for it but it gives
us this really interesting ability to
set up regular expressions and if we
have regular expressions we can do
something much more efficient than
brute-forcing we can actually look at
each character individually and
determine what those characters are and
what the position of the characters are
so let's go whoops what is that how do I
get back this isn't my computer help
where do we go no really you think it's
funny but it's not where is my Chrome
there we go
look at that so let's go you'd think
working on Chrome I would actually know
how to use Chrome unfortunately not the
case I just write code I don't actually
know anything about how this works so
we're on a web site we'll do we'll grab
a PHP session ID which is relatively
common it's much more common than it
should be basically every templating
language will have a session ID of some
sort because some people turn off
cookies so if we get a session ID
nothing actually happened that I saw
nothing happened on this page so of
course I'm perfectly safe unfortunately
that's not the case so if we go into the
network and then reload the page oh ha
ha
I need Firefox is there Firefox on this
machine is
that's awesome where'd my firefox go oh
look at that oh this is gonna be great
I need my net so it'd be really nice the
Firebug stayed open when I navigated
between origins so I'm a net let's
reload and I'm filtered to CSS there we
go so what we see here is that it's
actually able to read each character and
exfiltrate both the character and the
position to a third-party server so all
evil comm has to do is look at its logs
and it now has a session ID for a user
if the user has been to evil calm before
it also has a cookie so it's able to not
only identify the user but also get a
session ID which means I can just go
back to this website use that as my
session ID and for all intents and
purposes I am this user it's a kind of
interesting attack vector again it only
works in Firefox but in Germany a lot of
people use Firefox so it's kind of an
interesting thing to do here there are
other browsers it's all insane so we've
looked at CSRF tokens we've looked at
the get string and be really nice
actually if we could just steal any
arbitrary attribute on a page that'd be
kind of useful right because a lot of
pages especially in this brave new world
of single page applications are starting
the store things in attributes that are
really quite interesting for us so
templates did sort of data binding stuff
that's going on with angular and a
variety of other languages start storing
much more interesting things and
attributes than they used to and because
of that it gives us actually a really
interesting opportunity to start taking
more useful information than we were
able to get to before now this I don't
have any demo code for and set them just
I don't have any code to show you in
this presentation I'm just gonna show
you a quick demo so this is a proof of
concept and what this is going to do is
steal some information on these links so
let's say that we're in a a popular
bulletin board program that doesn't use
posts for its for its admin but instead
just says delete user and then has a
secret attached to that so as a get
parameter which is actually kind
common and now I'm back over here why is
that my antivirus is expired what's up
with that that's craziness don't have an
antivirus this is a Mac so if I reload
this page you'll see something
interesting happen right there's an
animation going on at the top and you
see some red stuff pop up and then go
away that's kind of interesting red
stuff popping up and going what could
that possibly be if we look at the net
tag then we'll see actually that what's
happening is the requests are somehow
being made and these requests are
exporting or exfiltrating information
about something that's contained in this
link how could this possibly be
happening the animation is used to
measure the width of an object why is
that important well it's important if we
construct a specially crafted font that
only has width for one character so T
has width but no other character has
width this allows me to measure the
width of an element with a with an
animation that says you know go down to
the right size and then come back I
measure the width by looking for the
presence of a scrollbar I can detect the
scrollbar because WebKit for amazing
reasons has a lot of scrollbar
properties and in this case WebKit
scrollbar track piece vertical
increments only loads when the scrollbar
appears most scrollbar attributes
actually load at page load which isn't
very useful for data extract
expectations but if we look only for
those specific properties that only load
data or only load resources when the
scrollbar pops up then we can measure
the width of an element's and then tell
an external server that this element was
this wide at some point which means
something in this case it means that it
contains an S or it contains a T this
gives us the information that we would
then need to more efficiently
brute-force a password or more
efficiently brute-force a took a token
of some sort you can actually make this
much more efficient by using contextual
alternatives in wofe contextual
alternatives are amazing they're really
very useful so if you look at this I
need to go back into full screen
if you look at this you'll see that the
text on the page is dear mom keep your
plates clean this time I will cook for
us this Sunday at 3:00 so it's a very
beautiful letter from a child to a
parent and we see that it's been made
even more beautiful by the presence of a
Waffen that says every time you see the
four characters de AR replace them with
a picture of a deer because a picture of
a deer is loveable and happy and makes
everyone just thrilled to get a letter
like this what it also does is allow us
to change the width of particular
strings of characters what this allows
us to do is to build a font that can be
used to attack people
you've heard of dictionary attacks we
can build a dictionary font so all the
most common passwords can each have the
first password can be one pixel the
second password can be two pixels the
next password can be four pixels and so
on we can use this information and then
using I'm sorry I missed something
the thing that's important that I forgot
to say is that you bring the data out
from the attribute by using a pseudo
element so you do like a after and then
in the after you use content and content
is a troop of href so you pull the
attribute you put it into the dom
somewhere where it can be measured and
then you measure it you saw that it was
like a five second animation you don't
have to wait five seconds you can
actually do it much more much more
quickly and this allows you to do it
even more quickly still because instead
of evaluating each character
individually and instead of having
defined twenty six different occurrences
on a page you can hopefully have one
occurrence and then look for the
particular word in order to determine
which of these things matches its and
I'm really excited about the potential
for media queries on elements because
that's gonna make something like this
even more valuable because you'll
actually be able to determine exactly
how wide an element is with pixel
precision with an animation you actually
have to do a timing attack you have to
look at the start of the page load so
you send some sort of information to the
server and then you animate and then
based upon how long it took you can
start guessing at which password it
might have been it's less useful than it
would be if we were able to pixel
perfectly measure each elements on the
page using a media query if we can start
doing
and I'm actually quite excited about the
potential for not only web components
but also attackers because that's gonna
be fun so anyway at the point here is
that by using a couple of different
properties of CSS you can exfiltrate
data that you really didn't expect to be
able to exfiltrate a dictionary fonts of
about a hundred thousand entries is less
than a Meg
so users especially if you look at
websites these days if you look at like
the iPhone 5s website it's like 17 or 18
Meg for the entire site which is kind of
ridiculous and in that context
downloading a Meg for a font is not even
gonna notice it's kind of cool again I
would recommend you look at those two
papers that I pointed out at the
beginning they go into a lot more detail
about the practical application of these
sorts of attacks what I want to do here
is just give you give you a flavor for
what can go on and what I'd like to do
now is tell you how you can actually
defend yourself against these sorts of
attacks the main problem that we talked
about it the main problem that I
expressed is that the browser executes
all the code that it sees and it
executes all that code in the context of
your origin which means in the case of
CSS but it has Dom access it can read
things from the DOM and can exfiltrate
data to third parties does anyone know
what this picture is
this painting okay a couple of people
this painting is Odysseus and the sirens
I think it's a really interesting story
and I think it's a metaphor that's going
to be a very applicable at a moment so
the sirens they sing beautifully so
beautifully in fact that it drives men
to the point of madness
especially sailors sailors are kind of
crazy anyway but with sirens they're
even more crazy and because of that they
just want to be mere near the music they
want to hear more music and they just
throw themselves overboard in order to
get closer to the music to hear more of
it throwing yourself overboard is not a
great way to steer a ship so Apes
usually then crash into the island where
the sirens live and I guess I don't know
they eat people who knows Odysseus is in
ego maniac and he is amazingly hubristic
because of this he wants to be the only
living person to have heard the song of
the sirens and survived he wants to
here this beautiful music but he doesn't
want to throw himself overboard that's
counterproductive in a deep way so what
does he do he tells his men to tie him
to the mast it ties hands behind his
back they bind his legs tightly which
means he can't get away can't do
anything then he instruct his men to put
beeswax in their ears and so you know
wrap things around their head is kind of
earphones or earplugs of some sort then
he tells his men okay row past the
island where they where the sirens are
don't go to the islands just you know
keep rowing ignore anything you see and
just you know get me past this island
the sirens come they sing their
beautiful songs Odysseus is driven to
the brink of madness but he doesn't
throw himself overboard he can't he's
bound from doing so and his men they
don't care about the sirens because they
have got stuff in their ears they're you
know humming to themselves who knows
they row him past the island he's able
to listen to this beautiful music but
he's able to survive while doing so
because he's given his men explicit
instructions and then he's prevented
them from doing things counter the to
these instructions it'd be really nice
if we had a mechanism to tell the
browser to only load the things that we
want it to load to only load our style
and not style from somewhere else we can
do this can do this with something
called content security policy condon
security policy is a whitelisting
mechanism that allows us to say script
from the source style from the source
but from no other sources please I want
only the things that I specifically have
told you that I trust here's some
information about my trust now execute
that within the context of a page I edit
the spec along with Adam Barth from
Google and Dan Bennett's from Mozilla
they are both very smart they tell me
what to type and I type it it works out
it's a beautiful relationship this is
the content security policy for a really
high value site my quest org you may
have heard of it it's really amazing
content security policy is best
delivered as an HTTP header the name of
the header is content - security -
policy and then you see a lot of
semicolon delimited directives each of
these directives controls a certain type
of content on a page we start by setting
a default source of
so we say no content should load just
don't load anything and then we slowly
open that up we say okay you can load
style from here you can load frames from
here you can load script from here this
gives you the very granular ability to
say origin one is something that I trust
that's my content delivery network
please load script from there if however
you see script from somewhere else don't
load it in fact through some sort of
interesting error like this refuse to
execute inline script because it
violates the following content security
directive those are excellent errors to
see this is a more or less exhaustive
list of the directives that exist in
content security policy 1.0 content
security policy 1.0 is available now in
Chrome as an unprefixed header it's
available now in Firefox also is an
unprefixed header I expect it will be
available in Safari 7 as an unprefixed
header because I landed that before we
forked and what's really interesting
here is the last directive report URI
report URI gives you a mechanism of
actually seeing attacks that are going
on so instead of just showing it to the
developer right at their workstation you
can actually post a message to your
server saying hey I tried to load some
information I failed miserably perhaps
you should look at that perhaps you
should take a look at this area and see
if maybe there's an injection that
you've missed this is what the report
looks like it gives you some context if
it comes from JavaScript we'll do our
best to give you like a line number and
a column inline script this is the last
thing I'll talk about inline script is
the biggest problem on the web in this
case I would say inline style is the
biggest problem on the web what do we do
with that it doesn't really come from an
origin right it's embedded directly in
the page what I would suggest is that
you externalize this information you put
it into an external javascript file you
do some Dom manipulation in order to set
up your event handlers or in the case of
CSS you simply load the style from
somewhere else then it has an explicit
origin we're able to vary in a granular
way determine whether or not we should
load it and the browser can do something
interesting based on that information
this is the only thing I want you to
remember from the talk this is the most
important thing I will show you today
it's an article written by an amazingly
some man and this article will give you
all the practical detail that you need
in order to take content security policy
and start actually applying it to your
pages it'll give you all the details
about all the stuff that's in one point
oh I need to update it from one point
one that hasn't quite happened yet one
point one is still kind of in
specification so there's a lot of new
stuff there's a lot of really
interesting stuff please at least
bookmark this article and tell somebody
else about it even if you don't read it
yourself I would really like to hear
from you guys what sorts of things you
see applications for with regard to
common security policy and any problems
that you see actually implementing on
your sites and with that I would say
thank you
you